it has been a remarkable last couple
hundred years where we have achieved
great outcomes in two world wars in the
battles of today we work alongside each
other in Afghanistan and in Syria these
are these are important undertakings we
have deep commercial ties and I know of
no other nation that has this unique
special relationship that is lasting and
as special as the one that our two
countries have and a special dimension
now we've got Americans in the royal
family yes a wonderful addition to the
special relationship do you think don't
trouble be bringing an American passport
for the new baby when he comes over next
time you know I guess I do issue
passports but I'll leave that I'll leave
that to others but you'd like to
presumably well all in good time we'll
work on these issues we're happy for
them the new touches of Sussex now that
I suppose the serious the top issue of
you on this particular visit has been
Iran you went at short notice to Iraq
this week what what is the immediate
threat you see from Iran so my trip to
Baghdad was to talk with the Iraqi
leadership based on some very specific
threats we had about Iranian activity
that was taking place that put at
substantial risk our facilities our men
and women who were serving in Iraq and I
wanted to make very clear to them that
they needed to be kept secure in the
Iraqi leadership was great and have done
that they're they've they've certainly
made that commitment but we also wanted
to talk to them about the fact we know
they're Iraq is a neighbor of Iran we
want to do all the things we can to make
sure that Iraq has the opportunity be
independent and sovereign and free from
interference from any nation any sense
you'll visit the moving-in of the
Abraham Lincoln aircraft carrier seems
to think you think there is you know to
use that phrase some kind of clear and
present danger from Iran we've seen
reporting that suggests we need to
ensure that we are prepared to protect
Americans wherever they are that is one
area where the United Kingdom has sided
with the other Europeans against the
Americans since the Imam as since the
Obama administration was replaced by the
Trump administration do you think we
like the British to switch sides and
join the Americans yeah I don't see it
that way we're on the same side when I
talk to foreign secretary how when I
talk to Prime Minister may they
understand the evil that emanates from
the Islamic Republic of Iran we've gone
our different paths with respect to a
particular deal related to one component
of the threat the nuclear file but in
every dimension we jointly understand
the risk of missiles coming from Iran we
understand the risk from Islamic terror
being spread by this revolutionary
regime and through Hezbollah through
Shia militias in Iraq through arming and
firing providing missile technology to
Houthis in Yemen we're in complete
agreement on those risks and we're
working side by side along them and
we'll find a way to work forward
together to make sure Iran doesn't get a
nuclear weapon as well I mean the United
Kingdom on the question of relations
with Iran and also more significantly
economically in terms of relations with
China is in a different position from
the United States it's not it's not a
competitor it's a trading nation that
wants to trade with both sides do you do
you understand that or do you think
there is a choice facing Britain on for
example Huawei which he talked about
well I'm happy to talk about Huawei
specifically but look we have a big
trading relationship with China as well
we want China to be a successful what
are you going to trade we want we want
the economic expansion in China for the
Chinese people as well but we want that
trade to be open fair free transparent
we want trade deals not to be national
security deals under a patina of
Commerce a China is a different nation
when it goes to Africa and offers
infrastructure it is almost always the
case that it has a national security
element to it we don't compete that way
the United Kingdom doesn't compete that
way and we want to make sure those
nations when they choose China know that
there may be some cheap deal or
something that appears cheap but we want
to make sure they know that that threat
is real and that if trying to loaned you
money they may well foreclose so how
does that mean the UK should respond
does that mean we shouldn't we should be
very wary of closer economic ties or
the huawei deal with China when it comes
to Wow way and ZTE the United States has
been crystal clear we don't believe you
can have those technology in your
systems and still have a trusted network
we're happy to continue to look at
technology and see ways we might achieve
that but the United States on for its
part will only participate in trusted
networks we will only share America's
information with those networks that we
are confident aren't under the control
of China or China's government and so
there's real risk if countries choose
that path that we won't be able to
participate in those networks this could
threaten Britain's security relationship
with the United States we'll find a way
I'm very confident there were two
important partners but we certainly will
never put America's national security
secrets in a network that we don't have
confidence in we never have we've faced
these risks before and we never will
could you do business with a United
Kingdom led by Jeremy Corbyn yeah I
don't want to weigh into that subject
they're a great partner they have a
special relationship it has survived
transitions of power on both sides of
the Atlantic I'm confident that our
nations would continue to move forward
together our relationship is with
Britain and I'm confident that we really
said for example something close to
jeremy corbyn's position on venezuela is
disgusting i mean that's a strong word
to use it's disgusting I repeat that but
this is supporting an individual Maduro
who has four years systemically looted
Venezuela and caused women to not be
able to feed their babies and to provide
medical care for their children the
medicine sits on they're very bored of
the food sits on their very border the
European Union and American taxpayers
were incredibly gracious that just
shouldn't be outside interference in
Venezuela yes well providing food to
starving children isn't interference
it's support it's what we do it's in our
deepest traditions if humanitarian
assistance
the interference has taken place the
Cubans are there they've interfered so I
hope mr. Corbyn will ask the Cubans to
cease to their interference in Venezuela
you've also just said that you believe
antes on
is the same as anti-semitism no there
many on the Left who dispute that who
say that you can have reservations about
Israel and particularly the behavior of
the Israeli government and not the
anti-semitic critiquing the policies of
the government Israel is completely
inbounds calling for the destruction of
Israel seeking actions that will lead to
its destruction that's not acceptable
this is this is what I mean it's it's
not it's not anti-zionism to critique an
Israeli policy set it is any scientism
to take positions which ultimately
undermine the democracy that exists
there in Israel and the human rights of
those as long as if you're worried that
the two are getting blood they are and
we need to we need to make sure that
we're crystal clear about that front is
it going to be easier for the United
States or more importantly the Trump
administration to have a relationship
good relationship with the UK once
brexit is completed I'm very comfortable
have a great relationship where as I
said in my remarks this afternoon were
ready to go to get a free trade
agreement once brexit is complete it's
an incredible important trading
relationship and we look forward to the
day we can begin to work together to
develop it so that we can grow each of
our economies together Trump supporters
the breaks to tears aren't they I'm sure
there's some that are and some that
aren't thank you very much thank you sir